all right super Bram Stoker's Dracula
fan here as I was looking forward to
this one let's talk about it
[Music]
Voyage of the Demeter is directed by
Andre overdahl and it's the story of
well the Demeter yes you guessed it
essentially it's one chapter in Bram
Stoker's book Dracula that's been
translated to the big screen in which
the ship that Demeter is carrying very
unsuspicious cargo a bunch of crates
that have really creepy Dragon logos on
them one of which is housing Dracula and
it's carrying him from Transylvania to
London I gotta say this movie is a story
that involves Dracula but it's not
really a Dracula story in the sense that
a lot of Dracula stories revolve around
Dracula or at least the way I like to
see him because Dracula is [__]
awesome this is the story of the crew of
the Demeter who are faced with a
situation of a monster is on board
killing them all one by one in that the
cast does an amazing job at keeping you
engaged I mean it's all a talented crew
Corey Hawkins essentially plays the lead
Liam Cunningham he's the captain of the
ship David Doss Mulch and you see what I
mean really talented crew it's something
about him
he is one of those actors that cannot be
Typecast or locked in a box pick a role
from a hat he can probably play that
role he's amazing now the overall
premise of this film is a layup on a
ship that's small enough to feel
claustrophobic but big enough to have a
lot of hiding spots there's a monster on
board tearing up the crew also the
monsters one of the most famous monsters
in all of literature is when the film
feels I don't want to say small it's
really hard to Peg the budget a lot of
times you can tell if a movie's a big
budget film or a smaller budget film or
indie film I can't peg this one I think
they use the budget really well most of
the time but I like the fact that it
didn't feel over produced I love the
overall practical feeling of this movie
when it comes to Dracula it was the best
stuff in here the creature design looked
great when it was practical with makeup
and even then there are different phases
of his creature design yeah at first he
kind of looks like Gollum and Barlow had
a kid he starts you know feeding and
getting sustenance and his design
changes to be more put together it kind
of looks like Nosferatu at a point which
is funny because Nosferatu was inspired
by Dracula you know Dracula's creature
designed in this movie kind of throws
back to Nosferatu so it's kind of a
circle of inspiration happening with
Dracula the best and creepiest scenes
are where someone sees him and they do a
double take and he's gone you know like
that's the nightmare fuel that is a
monster like this but as I said earlier
this isn't a Dracula film per se it's
the film about a crew that's being
hunted and killed on their Ship by a
monster that is Dracula sometimes in
cinema we'll get Dracula the man other
times we'll see a balance of the two in
this case it is Dracula the monster
there's this one lady she knows what
Dracula is and she says this is a
monster that can take the form of a man
that was such a great antithesis to how
a lot of people myself included see
Dracula it's easy to see him as a man
who takes the form of monsters but he's
not he's a monster the man is the lied
in this particular movie there is no
reason to be a man so let's just let the
monster out which means at times it is
hard to see him as a sentient being that
could do mathematics if there was a
chalkboard in front of him he more or
less he just kind of feels like a
monster you're seeing Dracula through a
keyhole in here there's one piece of his
personality but it is a piece that we
generally don't get to see and it's
unbridled unhinged fashion this is
Dracula the monster and you don't give a
[__] some of the kills were bloody and
satisfying there were also some moments
of vampire flavor vampire lore that kept
the movie from feeling like just a
general monster on a ship is there to
remind you hey this is a vampire story
as a vampire fan as a Dracula fan I
appreciate that this movie does feel
like it's at war with itself at times
because whereas the build up has such
great practical effects at a point
there's a little more CGI and it's just
noticeable the film was at its best when
it was building that tension when it was
going for that subtle creep Factor also
when it did some some dark things that
happened in here I just actually
impressed me and yes this movie is about
two hours long here comes the common
gripe but to be fair it's a common gripe
because it's so common that movies feel
too long this movie probably could have
been a half an hour shorter crew on a
ship getting picked off by a monster
known as Dracula I don't know why that
can't be just a 90-minute home run right
there and I'll be honest I didn't like
the ending of this movie because it
didn't feel like it mixed well with the
rest of the movie probably a studio
called everyone like you need an ending
like this because we say so I don't know
I wasn't in the room but if we find out
later that was the case it wouldn't be
the least bit surprise but if you look
back at the rest of the film it's this
dark Slow Burn horror psychological
torment Element film you know like
because they're seeing Dracula they are
seeing the impossible what will that do
one of the characters in here he starts
going mad you know I really like that
human themes psychological horror themes
and at the end you just feel like
are you trying to set up for a sequel
are you trying to franchise this thing
it just felt so weird I didn't like it
you still trying to make this Dark
Universe happen stop I get the story
goes on in the story of Dracula this is
chapter seven of Bram Stoker's book
there is a chapter eight but it's not
that kind of setup it's different just
didn't land with me the rest of the
movie generally did you know I got these
gripes here and there but in the end I
enjoyed myself if you're a Dracula fan
you absolutely should watch it I had
myself a bloody good time no alcohol
required all right last Voyage of the
Demeter have you seen it what did you
think about it what's your favorite
Dracula story you know Bram Stoker's
Dracula by Francis Ford Coppola that is
my jam I heard the one on Netflix is
good but I just haven't seen it so
anyhow let me know whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]